there's a certain level of protection
that comes with being one of the hottest
things on the internet and i think sort
of steve will do it and the knock boys
are
but
if coffeezilla was investigating me
i would fully [ __ ] myself steve will do
it and then elk boys you could only
create that in america
i think
like that there's a level of energy and
self belief and desire to make and spend
money that if someone's always a tesla
in the video yeah i imagine yeah yeah
permanently a tesla in the background so
yeah those are the huge creators online
and
they've been spending
a hell of a lot of money but steve
regularly spends upwards of a million in
his videos buying watches and buying
cars and then just giving he'll go into
a garage and say is that person trying
to buy a car and then say can i buy this
for you
he'll just like go to
he's
semi-adopted this young
school kid and bought him like a dodge
charger and that night the kid went and
got arrested in it because he was street
racing without the license
and then he picked him up from school in
some rolls-royce truck and said like you
can't do that again but here's like a
few thousand dollars for like making
sure you've got money for school for the
next day
so he just spends like absurd amounts of
money and they've got this
seltzer called happy dad which is like
quite a popular
alcohol
sparkling water you'd love that johnny
that's that's a bit of you
i've heard of that stuff before yeah i
don't really know why
like why is that better than it not
being sparkling water for example like
what's wrong with just normal i know but
what's wrong with just like normal mixes
like i get sparkling water as a thing
i get flavored sparkling water but like
it's hard seltzer anyway so apparently
they're crushing it uh and and they sell
loads of merch but they don't sell
enough merch to be able to drop half a
mil to a mill every video and he
releases one video a week did he not say
70 million
that's how much the merch makes yeah but
that's split between quite a few people
plus there'll be a must
even that doesn't cover him for the
amount that he spends in his videos
johnny's audit alarms are just like
[Laughter]
the tentacle
i mean remember for anyone listening
johnny is literally a trained auditor
like becca
so yeah he's just spending like tons and
tons of money and he was spending the
money since before happy dad and blah
blah blah and i've always watched his
stuff and i was like [ __ ] like this guy
does spend bank like serious amounts of
money he's constantly getting private
jets all over the place
and then coffeezilla
just decided that he was going to
do an investigation into him now
there's a certain level of protection
that comes with being one of the hottest
things on the internet and i think sort
of steve will do in the knock boys are
but
if coffeezilla was investigating me
i would fully [ __ ] myself
i would fully
cack my pants right there so thorough
really impressive i i just don't know he
do you reckon he's got a research team
that sit and like sift through videos
and then feed stuff up the chain maybe
surely he must do
because that's what so that's what mr
beast uh you can tell i've gone down a
bit of a mr beast rabbit hole he pays
200 people
to generate a hundred ideas each
for for a video
and then he has another team of people
select the best ideas and then they like
do a whiteboard day and hang on so he
has 200 000 video ideas
sorry
sorry 20 000 video ideas yeah 20 000
jesus and then they get whittled down so
maybe coffee zilla does but i don't
think
his
team what's his he's not got a massive
channel like he couldn't 700 000 he gets
a lot he gets very very high views for
his channel size
but yes i mean he did he did a brian
rose expose he did the save the kids
expose so he's taken down quite a lot of
people who
not untouchable not steve size but we're
pretty big dick i worry about his like
personal security as well to be honest
because he you're taking down you're
taking pot shots at people with well a
lot of money and are going to be very
angry at you taking part shots up and
yeah and then he's showing his face i
know he's not he's kind of
isn't he like he doesn't say his name
but i'm pretty sure it's going to be
easy enough to find that out isn't it
because it's just
it's defamation like he's completely
dragging him under the bus publicly on a
big youtube channel well that's only if
it's untrue
yeah that's true
which is the mad thing i can make these
wild accusations about you
and if i happen to hit the mark like if
i'm
and if it lands in the bullseye
[ __ ] game over so yeah i mean
they're going to see it as defamation
because they've got massive egos and
they're going to have all you know all
the people who he takes down have got
these weird like rationalizations for
why what they do is okay yeah so of
course they're still going to be angry
and like
he has to go through the the process of
proving it's untrue or true like you
know you know every course everything
could be true or untrue on the internet
until you take some sort of legal action
to
nightmare i would
be very very concerned if i was steve
will do it like
to have coffee zilla and then he's got
another guy uh some ordinary gamers
who's got a [ __ ] monster of a channel
that's really really highly engaged and
he does the same thing
exactly the same thing just internet
detective [ __ ] and they've gone down
this huge rabbit hole and it turns out
that they were
supported by rubette which is an online
unregulated offshore crypto gaming
company
and they basically all of the dodgy
words in one sentence correct correct
it's in the in the seychelles by
kurakawa or whatever it's called karasu
um yeah they've got this dodgy gaming
license it's illegal in the us the only
way that people can access it is through
a vpn
but because it's illegal in the us and
you can access it through vpn they don't
have to ask because of their gaming
license they don't have to ask for id
which means that all of the 14 year olds
that watch steve's content
can go and gamble with their parents
credit card and lose tons of money and
rack up these [ __ ] massive debts
and it seems like his earning potential
comes from essentially their losses they
call it
the mathematical house edge on all bets
that's what affiliates make money on
which is just
a nice way to say
if you're if you're affiliate to lose
money you make some of that money five
percent and then it scales yeah it was
like some
legal wiggly wiggly business that was
like
it's not the losses that you make the
money on but it's the percentage of it's
a derivative of the percentage of the
losses that you get
is it not just the odds
yeah but like obviously
it's it's in the house's favor isn't it
but that's the other one
it would it would just be giving money
away wouldn't it yeah
which wouldn't exist well to think that
five percent of the mathematical house
edge
means that there must be
an all-right amount to play around with
because that scales up that's what you
start at and then it continues to go up
so yeah basically and then it also turns
out that they're not using their own
money to bet so they live stream i've
never seen them actually do this i've
heard them drop the names of rubette and
wizard which are these two sort of dodgy
companies but i've never actually seen
them bet and i think they must do it a
little bit more on twitch or maybe they
did it in the past i don't use twitch
and
on some of the videos you see kyle who's
another one of steve will do it sort of
crew betting and he loses everything he
loses 30 grand immediately and one of
the guys that's next to him says we need
to ring howie it turns out that howie's
like the ops director for this place
it's like get the [ __ ] money fed back
into his account so they're not even
betting their own money they're live
streaming them betting money that's
being gifted to them by the company to
make it look like they bet and win
and then they make money from the losses
of the people who don't get paid by the
company to put the money in
yeah i mean where to begin with the
morality of that situation
and so that so this is what's funding
all of the flamboyant spending in the
video and that's just the affiliate fee
basically
so the affiliate fee is buying him like
100 000 watches private jets
it's what what's like the 25 year old
guy with the cap on in the back of the
video like the guy who runs the show how
much is he making
alan
alan alfonso yeah ellen you can't
did you see the bit in coffee zilla's
video he gets this little hamster he
gets a little hamster it goes helen
hello
he's left this like trail of
clues as he goes along and because he's
just filming everything i it almost
seemed like he's wanting to be caught
but then maybe it's just because like
they're such narcissists that they just
film their entire lives yeah maybe i
mean he definitely doesn't want to be
caught but i think what he probably does
want to do
is or what he isn't doing is he's not
being sufficiently careful
like if you're making so much money and
if all of your buddies are this rich why
the [ __ ] would you bother you feel like
you're untouchable
well that that video that is picked
apart that sort of starts the
investigation where he's just admitting
it
why on earth is that like why is that on
the internet because he could just be
saying oh yeah it's from the it's on the
channel and like there'd be a few people
who would know enough about it to know
that that's not possible but probably
not very many
like people with sufficiently big
youtube channels to know all those
numbers spent three years training in
audit
he doesn't know run the numbers like
when i when i first watched mr beast i
was like what on earth is going on here
like surely he's not making that much
money from these videos
but he's not he's a christian
he says like oh you know i pay 10 grand
to anyone who throws this ball into this
hole or whatever but it's not like i'm
gonna spend
a few million on
but but if you take someone who's who
who doesn't really
know much about like what's possible on
youtube which i suppose is most of the
people who watch youtube and show them
something like that it looks insane yeah
you don't know
yeah you don't know that um
steve will do it
putting five million views on a video
you don't know that that won't be able
to generate him the sort of wealth that
he needs to be able to fund that video
like mr b
mr beast has 50 million views
on a video and doesn't drop that sort of
money and then yeah as you're right
there's this live stream that
coffeezilla managed to get a hold of
steve saying i've figured out other ways
to make money dude you can't make this
much money from selling [ __ ] merch
like this isn't from the channel i've
had some advice from some buddies and
blah blah blah and you think man
if you're doing
online unregulated offshore crypto
gaming like buzzword buzzword buzzword
if you're doing all of the bad words in
one sentence don't [ __ ] talk about it
on a live stream okay
when he says like oh this house is
actually paid for by rubette
oh that guy do you see that guy did
bunny hops like one of the dudes told
him that he needed to hop up and down
like a bunny and he did it
yeah it's so weird
i don't understand the bunny hop thing i
think there's nothing more to it
like someone told
the guy that says oh i live in this
house and it's paid for by these guys
and blah blah blah one of the guys that
pays for the house must have been on the
live stream and asked him i don't know
like put a request in like you're doing
only fans i can have a photo of your
feet and put a request in from to do for
hop up and down like a bunny so he
pretends that he complains about it and
says why are you so [ __ ] weird and
then hops up and then goes and does it
[Laughter]
he's not the weird one
yeah
but he just knows like he knows he has
to
but it's just this is my life now so
yeah i think
it's a six part series and we're up to
part
two at the moment
this
this could be the sort of thing
this is the [ __ ] fascinating thing
right this is the really interesting
thing
is five million subs on a channel and
being the hottest thing on the internet
at the moment like can it save you from
outright undeniable fraud
legally or like from a brand perspective
both
both
i think like nobody outside of the
youtube world will care and you'll if he
gets caught you'll just get prosecuted
but i imagine he'll still have a bra
quite a strong brand at the end of it
that would be my prediction
yeah i think people
people watch videos because they're
entertaining and even if there's some
big even if the incredible goes on
people are well i still like it's still
dopamine at the end of the day isn't it
that's a really [ __ ] good point
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace